para la otan aún no hay señales de
momento de una desescalada militar por
parte de rusia a pesar de los mensajes
de que se podría producir una retirada
de tropas en la frontera con ucrania el
secretario general de la otan james
stoltenberg ha asegurado que a pesar de
todo seguirán vigilando atentamente la
situación en el terreno porque una
desescalada no sólo implica una salida
de tropas también de la retirada del
equipamiento militar porque si lo
mantienen este equipamiento podrían
volver rápidamente desplegarse estas
tropas algo que según ha recordado esto
ya se ha producido en otras ocasiones
aún así stoltenberg que sí ha admitido
con cierto optimismo el hecho de que
moscú quiera seguir manteniendo el
diálogo con occidente y seguir
manteniendo la vía diplomática aún así
todo el mundo quiere ser muy cauto con
esta situación de hecho los ministros de
defensa de la alianza mañana analizarán
una reunión aquí en bruselas cuál es
exactamente la situación porque según la
otan ahora misma europa se encuentra
ante la mayor amenaza a su seguridad
desde la guerra fría en todo caso el
mundo está aún pendiente de lo que puede
ocurrir los próximos días en la frontera
con ucrania aún así por parte de los
gobiernos de la unión europea y de eeuu
recuerdan que si hay una invasión a
ucrania rusia pagará un precio muy alto